[Musique]
aurelio de fringe à oreille a vendu
finaux spectre en tout cas tout se
ferait
donc là peu importe que je te dis tu vas
comprendre
non voilà
un anneau croissante aux
wheat sono
oui oui baguette waouh bravo mais c'est
tout noël assouan vous devez vous
coucher avec moi ce soir
au quai
à
nailloux dans la nuit
[Musique]
don juan monaco
[Rires]
tu toc site à atik c'était nerveux si tu
es nerveux tu pense à ce qu'a fait si tu
fais pas de café thé pas brésiliens
cités pas brésiliens tu n'oses pas à
samedan et sans bord et ben t'as froid
job et si tu as froid c'est l'hiver et
l'hiver si tu as froid tu vas abonnés et
si tu m'as abonnés tu m'épates hoc qui
quelques
mois dans la chambre et bien
aller mal dans ta chambre
en vo est en vie au lit
bonne nuit
être qu'on transpire à la piscine alors
sachez que c'est un des sports où on
transpire le plus le problème c'est
qu'on est dans le du gouffre on sent
alors il s'avère que c'est vrai j'ai
fait beaucoup de piscines et moi si je
transpirais mon
ire à mailhac lames en bois
quand tu es pressé sata iii son nom
tabarnak à ce moment il mouille mecs
parce que tu as fait de la glace
patinage artistique ça ne fait pas
partie des cours depuis 15
h darel vous réveille tout et vous allez
me voir westergaard moi j'suis piétons
si je préfère les transports en commun
ou bien est il besoin est mais quand
t'as pas de charme besoin de déneiger ou
moins mais quand une tempête les auteurs
de six passes justes
du match
dimanche
leur master vous bat pas de feignasses
capcom